2020 didn't give us
much but it did give us tick tock don't
be
rude are you kidding me i'm a savage
the platform had gen z teaching everyone
a thing or two
starting with the app's first breakout
star lauren gray
who until march was the most followed
person on tick tock
running as fast
[Music]
but charlie demilio and addison ray who
were also early adopters of the app
changed the game by quickly going viral
to hits like this
when i first downloaded take talk it was
kind of as a joke i think that's kind of
what everyone downloads it as
but i was babysitting a lot of like
middle schoolers at the time and they
all had tick tock i posted a video as a
joke and it actually did really well and
i was like very shocked
after that point it was kind of like
realizing like
oh my gosh like you can actually like
get somewhere with this app
the renegade took tick tock into the
mainstream
with celebs like lizzo a-rod and
kourtney kardashian paying attention
what does it mean when you hear from
stars like that and you see them
reposting the stuff that you do
it really it doesn't seem real because
i'm like why why do they know who i'm
just dancing in
my room by myself why do they know who i
am
the success of those viral dances made
charlie and addison
celebs of the digital age leading them
to los angeles
and a new world of content creators
what's up bt welcome to the hype house
i'm thomas the hype house
created a tick-tock real estate boom of
tick-tockers teaming up under one roof
to boost their content
and while these creators are trying to
establish their own stardom
lots of celebs turned to tick-tock to
reach a whole new audience
whether it was through their movies
bolton is not in my show
evaporate tall person their music you
know what to do
with that big fat butt wiggle wiggle
wiggle
wiggle wiggle wiggle or through their
[Music]
kids
tick-tock also brought us unexpected
moments from everyday people
like tabitha brown who went viral for a
cooking video for carrot bacon
which now has nearly 20 million views
i'm about to make carrot bacon and then
you shade it like so like that and then
make sure it gets thoroughly seasoned
put it in your airfryer or your oven
let's check the crunch
listen real good
yo in november tabitha got the chance to
cook that recipe on the ellen degeneres
show with tiffany haddish
we made carrot bacon have you heard of
it
uh i think i saw your video of it i was
like she crazy
okay yeah show me how to do this and of
course we can't forget
nathan apodaca who single-handedly put
fleetwood mac
back on the billboards hot 100 chart
with this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
you